all right
okay Welcome to our LinkedIn live
audience our YouTube live streaming
audience and of course everyone here on
the WebEx
live application and I'm here with
Bill Bailey who is expert
in cyber security
and he'll be
helping us go through our live look at
the cyber security boot camp
offered with the University of
California Irvine UCI
and their division of continuing
education
so
I'll let Bill introduce himself and
then we'll go into the agenda
well thank you for having me today
that's uh
and of course I'm sitting here looking
outside I wish I was on a beach
um but I'm not on a beach today
uh I have over 20 years of experience in
information security uh privacy and risk
I'm involved with uh isaka Issa chapters
on the boards
and over my years of experience you know
today someone said what's your
experience what's your background I said
well you know I started on the
Technology field and then I I said well
let's get a job in finance then I found
myself in healthcare and then I found
myself supporting retail utility sectors
been a consultant to travel around the
country been around the world and I've
actually been teaching I don't know how
many years it's it's we've uh We've
definitely we've passed I think 20 a
couple years ago so it's hard to count
now
um and so it's great
and you know set information security
policy for financial institution and
actually at that time I was part of they
had the ice acts and so I was I've
always been involved with those ice acts
as well and you really learn a lot in
all of those programs
great
thank you for being here Bill my name is
Stuart Creek by the way and I'm a
marketing manager with
simply learn and simply learn supports
the the UCI program by providing uh the
learning platform
and we'll talk about that in a bit we'll
talk about the cyber security career
field
why it's so important why it's so
quickly growing and why it offers you so
much opportunity
um
and we'll talk about then what this
program offers you by way of getting
into the cyber security field
and bill will help describe how the
program gets you job ready for that
field
um we'll talk about enrollment steps
have a q a toward the end of the session
so along the way as you get questions as
questions pop up in your mind please put
them in the Q a box for people who are
here on WebEx
um
and if you are on our streaming service
put it in the comments or chat of that
service so that we can
take a look at those questions
let's start off
by talking about careers in cyber
security and cyber security field itself
so a couple of quotes here
from pricewaterhousecoopers and um
they highlight
the challenges of cyber security
so the first quote talks about the
challenge of
securing systems and how difficult that
is and how much work is left to be done
a half or more of the
cios and
corporate information security officers
say they haven't fully secured their
systems
mitigated the risks
that are associated with all the changes
we've had in the last couple of years
towards work remote work work from home
um migration to the cloud our world has
changed great deal since the pandemic
much of what we do that we used to do in
person we now do virtually which means
that
the
quote unquote threat surface for cyber
security attacks is much much greater
and that's left businesses scrambling
um
has that been your experience Bill and
working with your clients
oh that's an understatement Becca what
was it March of 2020
uh in March 17th just a mad rush how do
we do this
yeah just to get everything done and uh
it was uh business what is the driver uh
that's why technology exists uh and then
of course March of 2020 it went out the
window to get the job done and we're
still finding it's a challenge to bring
security up back in or terrain to them
absolutely it's still still an issue
um just on the point of the the
transition and that happened in March of
2020
I remember going to a
webinar on
some
Venture Capital firms in Silicon Valley
you're talking about uh
the the changes and
one executive said you know if our
management had sold us
that we had to uh
transfer everybody to work from home we
would have told them it would take six
months and cost 10 million dollars
and when it happened it took us three
days with zero budget
um but the
flip side of that is in three days with
zero budget you really don't have time
to think about how you make all of those
home computers
secure and so that left this hangover of
security
the second quote
talks about the just general growth of
digital
technology in our world and how much it
affects our world uh so much more of
what we do is mobile
tend not to expect in some countries we
don't expect to go to a physical Bank
anymore we expect to do
um transactions and banking on our
mobile phone we
've got very many many countries
using our mobile as our payment
form instead of a physical credit card
so the mobile has become
a much more integral part of our lives
and corollary to that is the Internet of
Things where many many more
things objects systems places that we
interact with in the world uh have some
digital enablement technology so
all of that
again increases that threat surface and
it also increases the amount of data
that's coming
and
struggle to deal with all of
the data and the data streams
and creates the struggle to secure all
of those touch points and data streams
so that they can't be used against you
and
the survey said
um
the Executives that were surveyed
believe that cyber criminals are more
dangerous than you know actual nation
states who are trying to conduct a cyber
Warfare campaign
um because cyber criminals are so much
more numerous and so much more intent on
stealing from us
um nation states sometimes have to think
twice before they start out the Cyber
War so
um
again Bill how what was your what would
your views be on on that aspect of
well I think the Cyber criminals they
learn from the the nation states
so yeah it's and that's the scariest
thing is now oh the nation state did
this yeah wait a minute we can do that
too right there's a toolkit and it
you're not a script Kitty but you know
it takes some some work to do it but now
you want to attack an organization the
tools are out there and the the the it's
already been published oh well XYZ
company was breached by XYZ method and
now you can go do that wherever you want
uh and that whole notion of you know the
mobile and Internet of Things is you
know your your car is probably on the
internet and telling your your
manufacturer of your car all sorts of
statistics about your car uh your your
mobile devices yes you know I mean here
you know in the US we still have brick
and mortar uh Banks but increasingly
we're finding that uh a lot of the banks
they they would do these Acquisitions
and they'd have these great Footprints
and now they're realizing thing yeah
that's just going to be an ATM now and
that's all that we'll keep the location
and there's an ATM in front of it and
that's it so you know big and people are
just doing mobile technologies and uh
they're using different Payment Systems
you know venmo PayPal sell Etc uh to
exchange money so now
um you're seeing that mobile peripheral
yeah just really uh
uh permeate our lives uh that you don't
have to go to a fixed location you don't
have to hand you you know you don't have
to hand paper or metal currency to
somebody
you you just hit a few buttons and poof
it's there yeah and and there's a lot of
uh stories in the American Press about
Zell and some of the scams that people
are running
the
illustrate one aspect of cyber security
which is the human aspect so that's one
of the things that we talk about in our
course we talk about uh
cyber security skills
leading to careers and what kinds of
careers are those
you can be a specialist in the
infrastructure of security
Specialists looking at security aspect
aspects of networks and Cloud
you can look at security of applications
you can look at
um threats and trying to find the
threats you can be blue or red team
members looking at
penetration techniques and how to defend
against them you
can look at
um different types of malware and how to
detect and defend and also
you can go into developing you know the
cyber security tools themselves so
um
what are some of the other things that
I touch on here
bill
uh well it's interesting I'm looking at
the Q a as we go through this and I
every so often I look at this I go wow
that it's almost like this person knew
the question was coming up are there a
mix of Technical and non-technical roles
and and the answer that question yes
there are you do need to understand some
of the technology you don't necessarily
need to be a developer if you don't want
to but you need to understand how the
development life cycle works and that's
what we do in our courses is you'll be
uh you'll be acclimated I think it's the
right word I'm wanting to use here to
the the technical and we will show you
these different attack methods and
things of that sort uh and um and then
if you are doing like a risk assessment
which is a non-technical role if
anything uh risk assessments uh
governance risk and compliance they
start talking about more supporting the
business understanding the business
sense so you have to understand the
threats of course and then you can say
well how does this affect the business
and so I think to your question there
Stuart yes there there are some other
rules that people start looking into
like they become you know a be so or
they become a director of privacy and
secure security or you know the CSO is
sort of sometimes held up as the top one
but if you find a role you like and you
know and some people they just like
writing documentation
and if that's if
you know I and I joked with someone just
this morning about writing documentation
well we should have documentation and
that's what the Auditors look for is
documentation and but if you like
writing documentation That Could Be Your
Role so there's lots you know there's
lots of Technical and non-uh Technical
um and uh you know the and I'll answer
the other question I see actually in a
little bit so I think yeah all right
we're going to keep an eye on that chat
box though keep please keep those
questions coming because it serves as a
reminder for me when we go into the LMS
oh let me point that out to you perfect
and so that that leads kind of the
bridging question here the bridging
slide here is between the careers and
the and the LMS the learning management
system what are the skills that you're
you're going to learn you need to learn
a suite of skills in order to to be a
well-rounded cyber security practitioner
infrastructure Security application
security
um elements of cryptography
um
everybody gets excited about ethical
hacking and threat hunting there's also
malware and ransomware Analysis uh
application penetration testing
um and this is just a sampling of the
various skills and there's also various
tools that you need to learn so
in order to be able
to
take on roles in cyber security and
build a career that you can take
different levels it's great to have
a well-rounded background of this type
um
comments on that bill
hope you're for some reason your
microphone is muted ah yes I was double
muted
um that's that was the saying we didn't
say two years ago oh I'm gonna double
double muted uh the uh yeah
as far as having a relative skill set
absolutely and I think one of the best
examples I was teaching in class
recently and someone asked me oh well
dude if I if I'm going to do this role
do I need to understand about
penetration testing I say well you don't
have to do the penetration test but one
of the greatest things in the world is I
was on the phone with a colleague
someone I knew for years and we would
consider ourselves friends to a degree
and and this person said hey um how come
you haven't considered our our RFP yet
and I said well I did consider your RFP
but the problem was it doesn't have what
I needed it and he says what do you mean
we've always done it before and and it
was something where that I had stepped
into a role and and I was taking over
and I said I'm sorry you know I know
what's required of what I want from a
test and I'm more than happy to look at
another proposal
and so by understanding what was
possible I could even in my role at that
time I didn't have to do the test I was
bringing in a vendor to do that test I
needed to know what I wanted in that
test and what was possible in that test
uh to get the client you know the the
the organization what they needed you
know they needed a proper web
application penetration test and code
review and even though I wasn't going to
do the code review I still had to know
what was involved yep exactly
so we have a poll for the audience and
if you are watching on streaming you can
put your answer into the commenter chat
I'll start this up for the WebEx
audience here
and presumably you're all here today
because you're interested in becoming a
cyber security expert what has stopped
you from enrolling in training program
up to now
so we have a few reasons you can pick
one two three or four
um
because you can't find a program that
covers all the types of skills and tools
that we just talked about is it because
you don't feel confident that you're
going to get the kind of experience that
you can point to when you
go out and look for a position in the
industry is it because learning from
pre-recorded videos just doesn't work
for you
or is it a timing
schedule constraint so let me share the
result with you
and 60 of our audience
um the only real significant objection
that people have talked about here is
they don't have the Practical experience
they don't feel like they're going to
get something they can point to that
backs up their claim to be an expert so
let's talk about this program
the UCI cyber security boot camp
and how it
allows you to overcome that
so it is a comprehensive curriculum it
has an industry-aligned learning path so
that the courses take you through the
sets of skills that
companies need CI division of continuing
education works with industry and gets
their feedback on what they're looking
for in terms of people who complete
these programs it's a six-month program
we say it takes
you should probably plan to spend 10 to
15 hours a week actually on this program
because there are
weekend classes
two four hour sessions every weekend
you need to show up to
more than 70 percent of those in order
to be credited with attendance and
but you have to make that commitment you
also have to commit to doing the other
projects and Labs during the week you
can do those on a 24x7 schedule because
of the Learning Management platform so
this is a flexible program that allows
you to do the work on your time the one
fixed time requirement is that weekend
class schedule
the integrated case studies and Hands-On
projects that you do within the platform
so you don't have to acquire other
systems or tools download anything
you're able to do that on the learning
management system itself
and the results of those projects can go
into your
get portfolio to show off
and then online live virtual classrooms
one of the key difference oops in this
program is that
you are learning from instructors like
you know Bailey your your
uh interacting with them live during
this class sections you have the ability
to ask them questions in between get
answers during the week
um and you're able to interact with your
peers as well so
you are not learning by yourself on your
own from pre-recorded material yes there
is pre-recorded material in the class to
get prepared for each class session but
the real learning happens
facilitated by instructors
the end of the program you've earned a
certificate from UC Irvine that
attests to the fact that you have
completed the core courses successfully
and that you completed a Capstone
project that demonstrates your Mastery
of the of the material in those courses
so
you along the the course of this program
in the six months you'll be doing 35
exercises 10 or more projects
um culminating in a Capstone project
that ties together all of the skills and
tools that you've learned during the six
months into a demonstration of solving a
real world cyber security problem
uh you get to take master classes with
instructors from UCI during the the
six-month period they'll be talking
about Trends in the industry they'll be
talking about
Technologies and tools
you can earn up to 30 continuing
education units so if you are in a
position where your employer requires
you to prove that you're taking
continuing education or if you have a
professional license that requires you
to prove that you take continuing the
education this course program offers you
up to 30 CEUs
and finally the simply learned career
service so
we talk about getting into the industry
one of the things that simply our adds
to this program is
career services that extend for six
months beyond the end of your
certification so for six months after
you've earned your certificate we'll be
helping you with job search
resume rewriting interview prep
um and I'll describe that in more detail
in a bit
um so
talk about the program
what's it like
um
bill for you as an instructor
when you're conducting classes in this
type of partner
well conducting a class in this program
uh it's it's a different experience than
some classes I've taught where you know
it's this is not oh well it's not a boot
camp it's not come in for one week and
um we'll see you you know so you start
on Monday and we'll see you on Saturday
and that's the last we ever see you
um yeah we're spending that those months
together and everybody is working in
some capacity in cyber security so you
get to see people going through the
whole program over those months uh and
you're actually with the the certificate
program you're actually making a
difference in someone's you know career
not just the job yep and and you touched
on something very important um when you
said this is not a boot camp so we call
it a boot camp because
um it requires intensive immersive
education but it doesn't work like
the traditional boot camps that came
into existence in the last decade or so
you don't have to show up in some
strange city you'd be locked in a
classroom
or eight hours a day for a week
um and try to absorb everything in that
period of time
this is a program that gives you uh
more flexible schedule and doesn't
require you to travel anywhere you can
access the materials
um
from any web browser you want to do the
programming exercises on a
desktopper laptop because you'll need
the screen real estate to see the code
but
for pre-recorded videos for example in
preparation and their materials or to
catch up on a recorded class that you
might have missed you can certainly do
that on a mobile device so
um
again you don't get locked in a room
instead you get the freedom to live your
life as as you now do and just fit in
the learning on a Time
schedule that meets your needs it's your
lifestyle so
that's why we talk about the digital
boot camp is something fundamentally
different from the boot camp
Bill referred to
I'm going to talk a little bit about the
advantage of C Irvine
as most of you should know University of
California system is premier
public education
post-secondary system in
world
that consists of
at this point I think 13 campuses
University of California Irvine is known
for its technology education
and it's a center of teaching and
research and Technology
it has produced several Nobel laureates
also people with other
Fields who have won things like the
Pulitzer Prize
and it is
well recognized well known as
a leading University
in the technology field so when people
see that on your resume they will
recognize that the training came from a
top-notch institution so
we like to mention that
we talk about eligibility for this
program this program is very open
and do not require a
bachelor's degree a high school diploma
are equivalent
must be at least 18 years of age
to engage in the program there is no
minimum work experience required
although work experience is always
desirable
for these programs because it gives you
an idea of how
this technology and these skills fit
into a working world so if you do have
work experience that's a plus you do not
have to have a program in the background
you will learn programming tools and
skills in the program we have
courses that you can take if you need to
uh brush up or or get fundamentals
so you can
add those to to make sure that you're up
to speed with
whatever you need to know for this
program but you don't have to come in
with a programming background so this is
we're very proud that this is such an
open program that uh
it allows people at the beginning of
their career to get into cyber security
but it's also a comprehensive enough
program that if you are experienced
technology professional
want to Pivot into cyber security or add
those skills to the area that you're in
this is also a great program for that
so let's ask a second poll question if I
may
whole question is
how much experience do you have
just like to get a feel for who's in our
audience
pardon me for right rough voice here
you know just something while folks are
answering that poll question you know
how many years of experience do you have
you know do you have a cyber security
experience do you have technology
experience uh have you been supporting
technology systems even though you
didn't think of it as cyber security
because there is sort of that crosswalk
that I myself did many years ago I
started as that technology person and
then somehow I will realize oh there's
this security aspect of all these
systems
uh but you can also come from the
business because you understand how that
technology supports the business right
because you're using it in your data and
now you're seeing it through a different
lens yeah that's that's very important
um
if you're a manager of a particular
business area and you um want to
understand what cyber security tools can
be
support that area and defend that area
this is a great program for that
um so it's a
very Stark split
um
55 of the folks in the audience today
are have less than two years of
experience but more than a third have
more than 10 years of experience
and
and a few very few in between so but
it's always interesting to see that
distribution
as I mentioned this program addresses
both ends of that Spectrum so
this is where I am going to stop sharing
my screen and allow
Bill to take us through the learning
management
system on a very brief
tour of
capabilities
of that system so let me transfer
control to him
you have the presenter privilege
yes I do and let me share here and
hopefully you're now seeing my screen uh
we are so I'm going to mute myself okay
all right so um all right so a few
things yeah when you come into this and
I'm keeping a couple questions I saw in
mind as I walk through this uh I've
already logged into the
lms.simplylearn.com so I I come to this
screen here and you know you heard me
say this is not a week-long a week-long
course uh you know a lot of these the
certification programs you're used to
you go in and you have access to for
like a week and you know you get to the
end of that week and you could take an
exam and that's it the postgraduate
program in cyber security as an example
of one that I've selected here
uh when when I look at this here it's a
series of courses that are all related
together uh for to form a curriculum and
so that one makes them makes it
different right off the bat
uh and when you go into that program
uh you have uh they're they're pretty uh
prerequisites these are uh courses that
you know if you're if you're new to
technology if you're unfamiliar with
technology or cyber security you can you
can take these so I think so one of the
questions I saw asked how much do I need
to know about networking and so one of
the prerequisites that we have that you
that you can complete is this CompTIA
Network plus that is self-paced learning
you notice that these two prerequisites
they're they're self-paced so you know
you can you can get the the
prerequisites right here at your own
pace
um you know prior to yeah prior to
sitting in your first class or if you
say you're starting a live class on X8
um that you could sit that first class
and then you're in between those because
remember it's Monday uh I'm sorry not
Monday through Friday it's Saturday
Sunday so you know after your weekend
sessions you have a you have a little
bit of time during the week you can go
back and catch up on some of these
prerequisites and they are going to be
broken down into topic areas so if you
have a question about something you know
you could actually go in and say well I
want to learn more about cryptography
and you would look at the cyber security
course and you'd see a drop down for
that topic
the courses that you have like in this
program here yeah we start with an
introduction and we go through a series
of these individual classes here you
notice that uh the live classes right
now I I have great Fields here it's a
mix of self-learning and live classes uh
it is all online uh through is a
platform similar to this I know we're
actually transitioning to zoom in a lot
of cases because it allows actually
better interactivity than WebEx but you
could take it from virtually anywhere
and that's why we have that uh and as
Stewart mentioned uh there is a Capstone
project that is part of the program and
yes you need to you need to actually
check these boxes in order to get your
certificate at the end
but that being said in an individual
course and I just happen to be in one
about securing applications I popped in
here yeah even the course has a project
right uh and uh you have to complete in
this case you have to complete either
the you have to complete the self-paced
learning or the live classes uh and
there's an assessment at the end of the
course that leads you to this
certificate and then you can either put
this on your LinkedIn profile where you
could download that print it and so
forth so each step along the way you're
getting that uh you're getting that
achievement
uh and this one the build a hacker
mindset and defend against future
attacks we actually take you through
everything you need to become a
certified ethical hacker if you choose
to which is really great someone said
can you tell me about all the threats
um that are out there and you know uh
there are Frameworks that'll give you a
list of threats and in these uh this
class it is you'll notice this is
covered in our live virtual class
because this is using the latest you
know whatever's in today's news so yeah
we could be talking about an Uber breach
that was uh social engineering uh
attacked uh service provider of uber and
then just you know and Uber what ended
up being the target but they went
through someone else to get there uh so
we talked about that in the live class
we talk about the current events and
again it has its own certificate and
this is where you know this is another
one of these courses where yeah there
there's an online lab environment that
you step through step by step
uh you know in the self-paced learning
here you like I said it's broken down
based on topic all right uh and and
there are knowledge checks with the
self-paced learning so you're not just
watching a video you're actually getting
a knowledge check at the end of it
um there are different reference uh
documents that are all part of that so
you have something to look at afterwards
and again I just you know the this
program uh the you know back here at the
end here of course we have electives
that you can take as well so you have a
required series of courses uh you have
electives uh and certification at the
end like I said you get certificates
with
um you get certificates for your
individual courses and and then once
you've completed everything uh once
you've completed everything you unlock
that certificate
and uh and you do have access to a
community
um like a Blog Forum if you will uh when
you're in the program so you have
communication in between those weekend
sessions and the next weekend session
and I think I tried to answer a couple
questions there I don't see any other
questions specifically about that so I
think I'll hand it back over to Stuart
yeah and I think uh you touch you you've
shown something that touches on
Anthony's questions about uh I'm getting
oriented into the program
and understanding what's due and what
needs to be done by the next class
learning management system give you
prompts for for that to give you solve
the overview of the classes that you're
uh that are in your program which when
you're engaged in currently
um scheduled for the live class dates
and that type of thing so Anthony if you
have additional questions about how that
works please uh raise a support ticket
in the learning management system or you
can email me my email is in the
invitation you got for this uh session
today and I'll make sure that uh get
that question to our team uh make sure
you have support you need
um so thank you for that uh build it
that gives you the
the
understanding of how this program works
and talk about uh Theresa ask a question
is this a virtual only program or is
there an in-person option
um Theresa yeah this is a virtual
program in the sense that it's delivered
entirely online so there are no physical
classrooms for you to go to
um but you are going to the virtual
classroom in person
um so it's not
virtual in the sense of
massively online
courses where you're just watching uh
pre-recorded
or non-interactive content
um I'm going to talk about the
curriculum and how it builds up in a
stepwise fashion and as you saw in
bills presentation there
is a set of tick boxes for the different
courses you have to take them all but
you have to take them in sequence so you
start off with an orientation session
which is basically just
um here's how to use the LMS here's what
you should expect
um
with that you move into your first
module which is Enterprise
infrastructure security
that gives you a basic foundational
overview and then you move into
application and web application security
which goes into the specifics of how
your uh how you protect against threats
to a particular application
ransomware and malware analysis is the
next one and then finally ethical
hacking
that takes you up to
your Capstone project so once you finish
these four core courses
you should have the tools and skills
available
to do the final Capstone which is a
several three to four week project that
you do Under the mentorship of an
instructor you meet with your instructor
weekly to go over your progress
and make sure you're not getting any
dead ends and we'll talk about the
Capstone in a little more detail later
but along the way you get to take the
master classes with the CI instructors
and
these are electives so you don't have to
take them but you take as many as your
schedule and interests
permit and then
as I mentioned they'll talk about
emerging
cyber security threats emerging
Technologies what the industry requires
things like that that'll get you better
oriented into the field so
um that we think the electives are an
important part of the project or the
program as well
um there's a whole bunch of different
tools that you'll be exposed to that
you'll get
a chance to use
um
do you have any comments on this this
list here
you know
oh this is it's a it's a great uh you
know definitely when we look at the
ethical hacking and penetration testing
vulnerability assessment and penetration
testing a long title there
um yeah we look at all of these
different tools we look at Cali we also
look at Parrot we look at other tools
that are out there I know sometimes I'll
you know we have uh we'll walk you
through a very safe lab environment that
shows you step by step how to use these
tools like reading a recipe like a
cookbook recipe but then we also talk
about how to set up your own virtual lab
if you want to because if you want to go
outside uh and you you're motivated you
know we want to we also make sure that
you know how to go get these tools on
your own uh you oftentimes you you
download them set up virtual
environments and and that you know can
be a way of getting additional uh
hands-on experience
excellent
um
the goal is that you build up a
portfolio of projects that you can show
to Future employers and answer that
concern about I'm not confident that I I
can show that I have real experience in
the field well
the various projects and especially the
Capstone project
allows you to point to something that
says here is a problem that that I was
posed this is a problem that
um
is a real world industry related problem
and I chose to solve this this is the
way I built the solution so I designed
it here's how I implemented it
again it shows that you have Mastery
over the Concepts and skills that you
learned in the boot camp it shows that
you're capable of doing the work
in a
real world type of environment
meeting the requirements of
um
meeting the requirements of the industry
and it's very rigorous in nature you you
have to do the project and be successful
at it in order to earn the final
certificate for the program so this is
why we
have you work with your instructor to
make sure that you're on track and you
don't get lost in any rabbit holes or
dead ends along the way so
um we think this is highly valuable and
it's something that you could take away
from the program and show to folks
our program advisor from the university
is Julie pie
the assistant director of Technology
programs she works with
us at simply learn to make sure our
curriculum
matches the
ecis requirements
and
arranges for the master classes so we're
working
directly under the oversight
Dr pie so we're very pleased
um that this is a
UCI program and not just
simply learn program
with the UCI label stuck on it
talk a little bit about some learner
outcomes and we'll talk about the ideal
candidates for the program we talked
about people who can come in from a
non-technical background or from
high school diploma background and
wanted to get into cyber security
whether you're a technology or any other
person or non-technical
um working professionals and Technology
who want to add cyber security to their
toolkit and then
bill and I have mentioned managers
who are in various business areas who
need to understand how to manage the
cyber security threat environment so
we talked about or mentioned the career
assist service from Simply learn so
again
throughout the program and for six
months thereafter
you have access to a number of different
aspects of our services that help you
get that next job or move up in your
career
certainly we offer
ongoing continuing free educational
events and career educational events
the projects courses we talked about
build up your portfolio
and we have a partnership with Talent
Inc
which provides specific services to help
you land that next job or promotion
so one is the access to their job portal
which allows you to confidentially
search for uh certain key jobs that they
available through their employer Network
um sometimes when you put in a
resume out on a platform like indeed or
dice your current employer can see it
even if you tell the platform that you
don't want them to see it sometimes that
kind of just leaks
that doesn't happen with the resume
rabbit portal
more confidential resume review and
rewrite service extremely critical in
today's day and age because resumes end
up being seen before they get seen by
any human being and they go through an
AI bot process that
looks for the key information
matches with the job description
and understanding how to format your
resume how to word your resume so that
it can pass that process
get to a human evaluator
but still looks like a resume written
for human beings is a important skill
important art and so the
service allows you to go through a
couple of rounds of resume rewriting to
get your resume in the best shape for
that process
and then finally one-on-one interview
service which is important for everybody
because you're always going to be
interacting
whether you're looking for a first job a
new job or a promotion in your company
you're going to have to go through
several rounds of interviews with people
about technology understanding about
your soft skills about your cultural fit
with the team
and that requires you to be able to put
your best foot forward when you're
interacting with people one-on-one so
um this aspect of the
service allows you to practice
interviews of different types with an
interview prepared and subject matter
expert who can
help you probe deeply in and be ready
for those questions that will come up in
interviews so these are all
really valuable Services again for six
months after
the
earn your
certificate you have access to those you
always have access to the webinars that
we do on an ongoing basis
do
[Music]
one or two a week at least of
webinars that cover the industry topics
cover technology sometimes master
classes where an instructor will go
through a topic and take you through a
virtual lesson
how to
conduct your job search how to care and
feed for your career all of these are
free resources that we make available to
you so that
you can keep
this Career Development going on an
ongoing basis
and
um
so we have a question
this is pretty straightforward question
based on what you've heard today
are you interested
and enrolling in the cyber security
bootcamp
and give you about 20 seconds to answer
the question
that's a very simple question but
sometimes it takes a minute to
find the right button again
I think we I saw a question came up a
couple times this is not an internship
um it's a it's a training program that
sets you up for a career in cyber
security and with the goal being that
instead of an internship that at the end
you would actually you know with the
with the career services assistance that
you would actually be getting
a job that you would you would
demonstrate your Capstone project and
and then you could say oh this is a real
world project that I've completed and go
right into a role rather than hopefully
not have to do that internship exactly
so we don't guarantee that you'll get a
job from the program but we do
everything that we can to help you
uh do that the result of the poll 97
percent of you said that you're
interested in enrolling in the program
to allow me to share with you how to do
that
enrollment steps are really
straightforward I mean you start off by
emailing us and ask us at
simplylearn.net they'll tell you how to
uh get an application started they'll
tell you what you need to submit as any
documentation of for example your high
school diploma and age and
any other background
do an application review
assess your qualifications your aptitude
for the program make sure that
this is something that you'll succeed at
we don't want to enroll you uh
with the idea that you know this is
something I might want to try but not
really sure we want to make sure the
people who enroll are committed to
spending the time because it is a
important commitment and we want people
to be successful and happy done with the
process so you'll get an admission
letter once you pass that application
review
and the next cohort starts October 13th
with a welcome session the actual
classes start on November 12th
um the program
fee is eight thousand dollars U.S this
is a us-based program
so this is going to be
same price no matter where you are when
you enroll for the UCI cyber security
boot camp
uh do no interest financing for as low
as 704 dollars a month
um and you can ask your employer about
tuition reimbursement if this is
something that you're going to apply in
your current work your employer May in
fact have a reimbursement program that
will rep pay you for your fees once you
complete the program or sometimes even
pay the fees up front for you so you
need to ask that question of your
employer to see what their policies are
uh I can't say that because you are here
today there is an incentive for joining
that October 13th why this flashing act
now is there so if you email us at ask
us at simplylearn.net you can inquire
what that incentive is
go find out you get a discount off of
the
program fees as a gift for being here at
today's live session so but this applies
if you join the October 13th cohort only
so
with that we can move into questions and
answers again I don't need to have you
staring at
slide while we're doing that
and I know that bill you have answered a
number of the questions so far so let's
take a look at some of the new ones that
have come in
um
Abu bakar is pursuing a Bachelor of
Science in information technology
so what are some of the ways a program
like this certification program like
this could help him
oh you're uh you've double muted
yourself again uh Bachelors of Science
and information technology uh when I
read that I there's so many degree
programs out there and sometimes they
take a developer type of slant to them
uh and and where this would be this
would be a certificate that would
demonstrate that you've actually gotten
the specialization in cyber security uh
the other benefit and I'll kind of tie a
couple other questions together uh is
the prerequisite uh that was optional uh
gears you for comptia's Network plus
exam uh I believe one and I forget which
course it is really gives you the
framework to be Security Plus certified
uh and we have the ethical hacking
course which is the certified ethical
hacker and those are all great
certifications by their own right and so
that's a that's an added bonus you're
getting a a certificate for the program
and you're getting the knowledge to
attain other certifications and and
someone had said in the in another
question says can I get a cyber security
role with just the security plus you
could get a role with Security Plus
certification and and what this program
would do would be to try to take you to
the next level because like that ethical
hacking takes the concepts of Security
Plus and ramps them up quite a bit and
teaches you how to be more aggressive
and uh
and but ethical at the same time
interesting question from asood uh can
Iranians participate in the boot camp is
there a chance for Iranians to get a
cyber security job in the United States
and I can say uh simple learning is
company based in India you would have to
check probably on one of our other
programs this is probably not a program
that you would be able to uh this
particular UCI program
in conjunction with an American
University it's probably not open to
Iranian Nationals enrolling from Iran we
have other cyber security programs from
Simply learn however that are targeted
at people outside of the U.S
and you might want to check to see if
any of those are open to Iranian
Nationals again simply learned as an
Indian headquartered company its
policies
may be different from
us-based companies on participation of
folks in Iran
um
G2 has path is your YouTube audience is
past 12. so I assume that's the high
school diploma and what path can he take
now for um
cyber security career you want
ultimately to become a ciso
well that's one of the things that you
know as a as a ciso I always have to
double check to make sure I didn't mute
myself
[Laughter]
the the ciso is is a career objective
for many people
um that they want to be when I grow up I
want to be a CSO I want to be fired the
next time there's a breach and I laugh a
little when I say that but sometimes
csip gets used as a scapegoat
um but you have to have the
understanding of network plus Security
Plus the certified ethical hacker the
penetration testing you have to
understand what the developers are doing
and things of that sort
um and I'll sort of wrap up a couple
questions I'm seeing here that are
related is
um we we prepare you along the way and
as I mentioned a lot of these courses
have direct like certifications that you
could that you could attempt we don't
guarantee that you'll pass those exams
because the only things we can guarantee
in life are death and taxes we do
everything we can to prepare you for
them
um they're not included the the
certification exams are not included so
the best of my knowledge although I will
say from my own personal experience it
was some of the best money I ever spent
as I was going through my career was to
pull my own credit card and to plunk
down the cash to take that exam you know
whether I got reimbursement or not to
get me where I wanted to be in my cyber
security career
the question from managa we asked about
procedures for Indians and what I'm
going to do right now is I'm going to
put into the
chat the uh
link
both for the email address ask us at
simplylearn.net and also the link to the
program page and if you are not in the
United States you may come up with a
slightly different page where the page
may not show you all the options because
it's localized this is a program
generally designed for folks in the US
however from that page you can navigate
to our other cyber security programs
that may be available in your local
country so uh for a non-us users it's
worth going to that page as well
um and as an Indian company as I
mentioned we have
lots of training opportunities for folks
who are in India
um
Brian asked a great question are there
project and program management
opportunities that have an emphasis on
cyber security
absolutely I but I've talked to a few
people over the last couple months and
they were project manager program
manager type of roles but that
um I I talked with a colleague and they
were looking for someone who was going
to help them with the security of their
development life cycle
okay
um you had mentioned documentation as a
career path and John Young asked my
understanding is documentation writing
is done by teens who author corporate
cyber security policies
collecting and presenting documentation
to Auditors in the form produces done by
the cyber security teams
um so can you comment and clarify on
that is there a divide between the
policy documentation and the auditing
documentation
absolutely well uh is there a divide
where there's a definitely a divide into
who's preparing it uh and the audience
that it's for and the criteria that goes
into it said and I saw that question
come from John
um there there are policies that you see
come from up high and that's your your
governance your risk and your compliance
you've got Senior Management who will
enact a policy
uh and then but everybody in the
organization uh if you're developing a
system you should be documenting the
development of the system you know
comments and source code things of that
sort
um when you're coming up with an
architecture you should be documenting
all the security requirements and part
of that documentation are the threats
that are in there and we might say it's
a privacy threat assessment or privacy
impact assessment we have a lot of
alphabet soup out there uh and that's
where you the whole information
technology and information security and
your project management teams yeah
they're making sure that the
documentation is created so that the end
users can actually use it because it's
more than just policies uh and when we
talk about Enterprise information
security I I believe that's one of the
we talk about the difference between
policies procedures and baselines and
guidelines and you know we have Auditors
and we have both internal Auditors and
external Auditors and and it's funny
we're talking you know UC Irvine and it
Calif California has several privacy
privacy laws in place so you may have
your state looking at your at your
organization also
um and so like you start and you say
okay I'm going to have the system I'm
going to have this documentation about
the system and I'm gonna I'm going to
have processes that are going to gather
documentation about that system or you
know statistics about the system
so that when I do have to talk to the
auditor or the regulator or the examiner
whatever it may be you know it really
that documentation is a complete life
cycle and it's not just Senior
Management and it's not just Auditors
everybody is comes gets involved with it
in their own way
uh Alpha asks a question I think this
will be an excellent question uh
candidates in Canada how much are the
fees for them and it will be eight
thousand dollars U.S uh uh the fee for
this program is fixed at that
um it is available to folks in Canada
North America Latin America uh it's not
really targeted at
uh folks uh on the other side of the
world Europe Africa Middle East Asia
um we have other programs that are
targeted to that audience
um so we
focus our efforts here although you can
enroll
um from anywhere we focus this program
on a U.S audience in North American
Latin American audience as well
um I will say for the folks in Canada
unfortunately are
Career Services may not be available to
you because those are specific to the
United States so you may have that may
be one aspect of the program that's not
open to you but
again
it's a fixed
same three wherever you are eight
thousand dollars U.S do email us at ask
us at simplylearn.net and put that into
the chat and question and answer box
um to ask about the incentive for
joining the program cohort that starts
on
October 13th
with that I'm going to ask one last
question
this last question of the audience is if
this is something that
you want to get involved in if you want
to enroll in this program when do you
want to do it
do you want to get into that October
13th uh cohort
possibly get the the
take advantage of the discount
um this is something that you look to do
somewhere further down the road
uh we always say that if it's going to
change your career and life for the
better worth doing now that's always a
personal decision but I'm
about two more seconds
share with you the result
of the poll results
a little more than a third of the
audience will want to get involved right
away so please do email ask us at
simplylearn.net right after this program
and ask that question find out how to
get started
within three months and uh let us do a
little less than a third
so yeah we do have other cohorts and you
can actually see on the program page the
date of the one after the October 13th
um folks who are looking six months or
more than six months out you can ask at
ask us at simplylearn.net what the
future cohort dates might be or
wait until you're closer to being ready
but we will be here the UCI program will
be here
and we'll be ready to help you so
with that I'd like to
thank bill for being here and taking us
through the program but also helping us
with his
expert knowledge of the industry and his
experience so thank you very much Bill
thank you I look forward to seeing folks
join a cohort great and uh I I do the
same I hope we can welcome you into the
UCI
Learning Community with simply learn and
thank you all for being here today so
with that
conclude our webinar